[Musica]
[Applauso]
una notte di tre anni fa mi trovavo in
messico nella penisola dello yucatan di
una foresta mai a quella sera eravamo a
cena ospiti da un capo indigeno che
durante la cena inizia a raccontarci di
storia di fantasmi di spiriti che
abitavano lì tutti attorno a noi di
quella sera particolarmente mi ricordo
di questo suo racconto di questa donna
quei capelli neri e vestita di bianco
che si è incontrata di notte ti prendeva
e ti portava via lei era stabile
finita la cena ci guarda e ci dice bei
ragazzi se volete vi porto nella giungla
a vedere un pozzo d'acqua e così magari
nel frattempo incontriamo anche se vai a
noi un po timpani katia tutte queste
storie ci guardiamo negli occhi mentre
cerchiamo una risposta lui prende il
fucile ci guarda e ci dai
forza andiamo iniziamo a camminare
cheadle chiamano sentiero in questa
giungla selvaggia fino a quando certo
punto luigi a destra e si intero c'è più
iniziamo inoltrarci in questa foresta
oscura dove è praticamente non si
sentiva altro che animale che si
mangiava gli uni con gli altri
quando certo punto lì si ferma
all'improvviso c'è ragazzi sfide luci
spegniamo le luci in quel momento mi
sono accorto di quanto il buio fosse
buio di quanto fosse penetrante di
quanto fosse pesante all'interno dei
medi quanto mi desse fastidio il mio
stesso respiro sopra di noi non vediamo
neanche le stelle non c'era neanche un
bagliore di luce e davanti a noi
qualcosa si muoveva c'è un qualcosa di
enorme che si muove davanti a noi che
rompeva le foglie che si striscia va a
terra che si riceva gli alberi e si
dirigerà verso di lui allora il commento
ho pensato dio sarà un giaguaro quella
zona è stata i giaguari
di qui non usciamo vivi e mentre preso
dalla paura e dall'angoscia pensavo
tutte queste cose
il rumor è scomparso in quel momento
sento una mano che mi tocca e mi dice
agostino poi accendere le luci era il
capo indigeno che ci davano ok
accendiamo le luci ci guardiamo negli
occhi eravamo terrorizzati ci giriamo è
cominciato a camminare la foresta
dopo qualche mese sono tornato in puglia
appena tornato in puglia e mi sono
accorto che pian pianino il mio orecchio
inizia a crescere cresceva cresce a
diventare sempre più grosso più duro più
gonfio ha iniziato a preoccuparmi quindi
sabato a roma milano in un sacco e
centri specialistici per cercare capire
cos'è che stesse succedendo
nessuno aveva idea abbiamo ricoverato in
ospedale ci sono rimasto per quattro
mesi internato e alla fine dopo questo
calvario è venuto uno di questi dottori
di roma che mi dice caro agostino
entrerà in messico una notte una zanzara
ha pizzicato sull'orecchio e ti ha
lasciato questa malattia terrificante
che una lesmaniosi ovvero un protozoo
che pian pianino ti mangia la pelle poi
la carne poi entra nel sangue ti mangia
gli organi interni
quindi uscito dall'ospedale io ho
bisogno un po di tranquillità di un po
di ritrovare un po di tempo anche per me
stesso per cercare di guarire da questa
cosa è suonato in salento ci va da
quando ero piccolo
però appena arrivato in salento mi sono
accorto che c'è qualcosa di strano tutto
attorno a me
la natura era tutta completamente morta
tutti questi adele olivo che ero
abituato a vedere da quando ero piccoli
enormi millenari maestosi dove andrò a
giocare con i nemici erano tutti quanti
morte e quindi pian pianino iniziato a
farmi e donne ma perché sta succendo
questo ho iniziato ad incontrare dei
cercatori ho incontrato ha iniziato il
cotral e tanta gente per chiedere
ma cos'è questa malattia e lì sono
finalmente venuto a contatto con l'acsi
della fastidiosa la xvi è la fastidiosa
un batterio arrivato in italia in puglia
il 2013 attraverso una pianta di caffè
importata dal costa rica arrivata a
gallipoli e dintorni di gallipoli è
stata poi mozzicata da volgarmente detta
sputa china un insetto che mordendola
piante infetta ha preso il batterio
nella sua saliva e l'ha trasportato su
una pianta di olivo e poi da lì è
iniziato il macello se la fastidiosa la
conosciamo che in puglia a dar più in
cinque anni sale con una velocità di 30
km all'anno verso nord e in cui li
abbiamo più o meno 60 milioni di alberi
di olivo e di questi 60 milioni 20 sono
già infette e tantissimi sono morte
quindi mentre noi in questo dvd
millenari insieme al fratello insieme
amici e ci chiediamo ma perché sta
succedendo questa cosa tornavano a casa
è quasi più la voglia di parlare con
nessuno per disperazione alla vista di
questi giganti che era lì che morivano e
soffrivano
in tutte queste ricerche io andavo in
giro costantemente coperto con una benda
bianca sull'orecchio destro per coprire
insomma il macello che sta succedendo il
sotto e quando incontravo qualcuno
supermercato albaro in pasticceria a
tutti quanti mi chiedi romana che ti è
successo all orecchio poi pugliesi
siamo molto discreti no siccome non ho
voglia di raccontare ogni volta si è
stata una zanzara che mi ha lasciato
questa malattia tropicale che è così
quello e quell'altro e li guardava gli
occhi
guardi signora mia mozzicato lo squalo
oppure una volta in colombia ha
conosciuto la ragazza colombiana che
durante un altri passione oppure è stato
un fulmine che mi ha preso su un
grattacielo di new york
un po come se un albero millenario
potesse dire al contadino che gli passa
davanti
guarda io sto morendo perché un'orda di
imprenditori pugliesi
vogliono morto oppure perché no una
grande multinazionale decise sterminarci
tutti oppure è colpa degli stranieri che
sapete quella cosa più divertente di
raccontare questa storia è che la gente
ci creda perché noi come esseri umani
abbiamo una grandissima paura del buio
abbiamo paura di tutto ciò che ignoto
abbiamo paura della morte e quindi
quando ci confrontiamo con qualcosa che
non ha grande senso per noi ci crediamo
dentro noi stessi e cerchiamo una
risposta in qualsiasi cosa ci passa
davanti però io sono convinto che in
questo buio ci sia comunque una mano che
ci venga accanto e circa guarda forse un
giorno andrà tutto quanto bene e questa
mano e la mano della scienza in questi
anni incontrato tantissimi ricercatori
che in oltre 80 paesi del mondo continua
a ricercare su xvi alla fastidiosa il
patogeno vegetale più pericoloso al
mondo che noi abbia avuto la sfortuna di
ricevere in puglia e con metodi naturali
e chimici stiamo cercando di tutto
fermare l'avanzamento di questo patogeno
e dall'altra parte di salvare quegli
oliveti monumentali ormai già infette e
che dovrebbero idealmente morire a
gennaio sono tornato a milano l'abbia
dottore
l'ho guardato e lui mi ha detto a orago
stino ormai non c'è più niente da fare
bisogna tagliare orecchio quindi in quel
momento io mi pesa grandissimo angoscia
non sa proprio cosa fare ha detto cosa
faccio non posso mollare in questo modo
non posso lasciare che la malattia e
prenda non possa cadere nel buio non
uscirne più
quindi iniziato a ricercare e ho
scoperto che in colombia il
nell'ospedale militare forse lo sapevano
come guarire questa mia malattia
ho preso il primo gol e sono andato a
rotoli
mi hanno visitato e dopo un mese e mezzo
di termoterapia mi hanno guarito
insomma mi hanno vinto con l'acqua calda
dopo oltre due anni di chemioterapia e
cose terrificanti che mi hanno fatto in
italia con l'acqua calda del guarito
quindi vanno penso a quella mano della
scienza che ci prende cice guarda
agostino forse sarà tutto quanto ok
allora ci sta installando come speranza
per i nostri ulivi monumentali la
tecnica dell'innesto è una tecnica
millenaria che conosciamo da tantissimo
tempo e che soliti se utilizzata con
criterio può forse salvare nostro io
monumentali ovvero prendendo delle
varietà tollerante resistente acsi alla
fastidiosa è in estate sugli monumentali
si può sperare di dare una continuità di
vita questi a questi gigante quindi e se
a mio fratello ad altri amici un paio di
mesi fa abbiamo iniziato a fare questo
lavoro su ulivi monumentali giu il
salento e speriamo di continuare a farlo
ancora per tanto tempo per dare un po di
speranza nostra terra
quindi un po come nella mia malattia io
sono convinto che quando il buio sia
così buio ma così buio che facciamo
fatica a respirare
noi dovremo sempre sperare
in una mano che ci tocchi e che ci dica
che insomma alla fine tutto andrà bene
poi tornando a notte i tre anni fa li
nella giungla buia maya tornando verso
casa e mi avvicino al capo indigeno e
gli chiedo ma mai fra in cos'era quella
cosa davanti a noi era era un giaguaro
lui si ferma
mi guarda e mi dice agostino se fosse
stato un giaguaro
ora lo saremo vivi grazie
[Applauso]